حدث هذا الآن في روتشستر بنيويورك،
أشاهد مقطع فيديو تراه هناك يُظهر
سيارة الدفع الرباعي مشتعلة بالنيران بعد
اصطدامها بسيارة كانت تنسحب
من ساحة انتظار السيارات، وتقول الشرطة إن المركبات
صدمت بعد ذلك حشدًا من الناس في
ممر للمشاة خارج  مكان الحفل الموسيقي،
يمكنك الآن رؤية علب الغاز على
الأرض خارج سيارة الدفع الرباعي المتفحمة، كما
يقول رئيس الشرطة، وقد عثر المستجيبون الأوائل على ما
لا يقل عن اثني عشر منها داخل
السيارة وحولها، وقد أدى الحادث إلى مقتل
شخصين على الأقل وتم إخبارنا سائق  سيارة
الدفع الرباعي في المستشفى مصابة
بإصابات تهدد الحياة، إليك كيف
يصف الأشخاص في الحفلة الموسيقية
المشهد، كان على بعد حوالي 20 قدمًا فقط من
المبنى وفي الوقت الذي
كان فيه الجميع يخرجون،
ربما كانت النيران لا تزال على ارتفاع 15 قدمًا تقريبًا أثناء
سيرنا  نزولاً إلى الردهة ونزول
الدرج،
كانت رائحة البنزين شديدة للغاية
ولم أستطع أن أصدق مدى قوتها